FOUR IN HIS RACE.
HERE WITH THE VERY LATEST, TWO
OF THE MOST ACCURATE POLSTERS IN
AMERICA, CHIEF POLLSTER AT THE
TRAFALGAR GROUP, MATT, WHAT I
SAW THAT WAS MOST INTERESTING,
"USA TODAY" SUFFOLK POLL SHOWING
THE PEOPLE THAT ARE BREAKING
LATE, IDENTIFIED THEM ABOUT 16%
ARE NOW GOING OVERWHELMINGLY TO
THE GOP.
DO YOU SEE THE SAME THING IN THE
POLLS YOU'RE LOOKING AT?
>> I THINK ROBERT IS GOING TO
AGREE WITH ME WITH THIS.
YES, WE SEE LATE BREAKERS GOING
REPUBLICAN.
BUT WE SAW THREE WEEKS AGO AND
WE SAID THIS ON YOUR SHOW THAT
WE SAW A WAVE DEVELOPING ACROSS
THIS COUNTRY MOVING TOWARDS
REPUBLICANS ANYWAY.
SO IN A SENSE, WE FEEL LIKE THE
STORY IN "USA TODAY" IS LIKE
PLAYING CATCH-UP TO EXPLAIN WHY
SUDDENLY ALL THE POLLS ARE
SHOWING REPUBLICANS WINNING.
WE'VE BEEN SHOWING THE
REPUBLICANS GAINING IN ARIZONA,
PENNSYLVANIA.
EVEN IN NEW HAMPSHIRE, WHICH
COULD BE THE UPSET SPECIAL OF
THE NIGHT.
WE'VE BEEN SEEING IT GOING ON
3 1/2 WEEKS AND SEEMS TO KEEP
BUILDING.
OUR LATEST POLL IN GEORGIA,
HERSCHEL WALKER IS MAKING
INCREDIBLE MOVES VERY LATE IN
THIS RACE AFTER HE'S BEEN BEATEN
TO DEATH ON TELEVISION WITH ALL
OF THESE ADS.
>> Sean: THAT'S A STATE WHERE IF
YOU DON'T GET 50% PLUS ONE,
YOU'D HAVE A RUN OFF ON DECEMBER
6, CORRECT?
>> THAT IS CORRECT.
IT'S STILL HIGHLY POSSIBLE THAT
HE COULD BE IN A RUN-OFF,
ALTHOUGH IT WILL BE BETTER ANY
TIME FOR ANY REPUBLICAN BECAUSE
THEY HAVE SHORTENED THE TIME
PERIOD OF THE RUN OFF SO YOU
DON'T DRAG ON UNTIL JANUARY.
THAT WOULD BE TO WALKER'S
BENEFIT.
>> Sean: ROBERT, SAME QUESTION.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
THAT'S THE ONE THING THAT WE'VE
BEEN TALKING ABOUT.
WHEN WE MEASURED THESE
UNDECIDEDS, ALMOST EVERY TIME,
BREAKING VERY MUCH ANTI-BIDEN.
WE'RE NOT SHOCKED WHEN THE
UNDECIDED END UP IN THE
REPUBLICAN COLUMN.
60, 70% OF UNDECIDEDS IN EVERY
RACE ARE ANTI-BIDEN.
>> Sean: LET ME ASK YOU BOTH A
DEMOGRAPHIC QUESTION AND GO
THROUGH THE INDIVIDUAL RACES.
DEMOGRAPHICALLY, I'M SEEING IT
IN YOUR POLLS, ROBERT, I'M
SEEING IT IN YOUR POLLS, MATT,
BUT IN OTHER POLLS AROUND THE
COUNTRY AS WELL,
DEMOGRAPHICALLY, WE'RE SEEING
WHAT I BELIEVE TO BE A BIG SHIFT
IN TERMS OF AFRICAN AMERICAN
VOTERS, HISPANIC AMERICAN VOTERS
ARE MOVING IN BIG NUMBERS TO
REPUBLICANS.
I'LL GIVE YOU TWO STATES,
GEORGIA AND PENNSYLVANIA.
MATT?
>> YEAH, THIS IS BECOMING COMMON
NOT JUST IN THOSE STATES BUT
ROBERT AND I BOTH KEEP GETTING
THESE CROSS TABS BACK.
WE CONSISTENTLY SEE WHERE THE
AFRICAN AMERICAN VOTE ABOUT 20%
OR MORE ARE GOING FOR REPUBLICAN
CANDIDATES.
WHEN IT COMES TO EITHER HISPANIC
LATINO OR WHAT WE CALL OTHER.
SOMETIMES IT'S 60 SOMETHING
PERCENT FOR THE REPUBLICAN.
NOT ALWAYS.
THESE ARE THINGS THAT WE'VE
NEVER SEEN BEFORE.
I'VE NEVER SEEN REPUBLICAN
CANDIDATES GETTING 20% OF THE
AFRICAN AMERICAN VOTE THIS CLOSE
TO AN ELECTION.
CERTAINLY HAVE NEVER SEEN
HISPANIC, LATINOS OR OTHER RACES
TRENDING REPUBLICAN LIKE I'M
SEEING IN THIS PARTICULAR YEAR.
>> Sean: ROBERT, I'M LOOKING AT
YOUR POLL.
I SEE YOU'RE PICKING UP THAT
TREND AS WELL.
>> VERY MUCH SO.
THE TWO STATES YOU MENTIONED ARE
PARTICULARLY INTERESTING WITH
WALKER DOING 23% AMONG BLACK
VOTERS.
GOVERNOR KEMP IS DOING 20.
WHAT IS REALLY FASCINATE
IN
OZ IS DOING.
WE HAVE OZ IN THE 30s AND THE
ONLY ONE IN THE COUNTRY BREAKING
20% WITH AFRICAN AMERICAN WOMEN.
>> Sean: ALL RIGHT.
LET'S GO TO THE STATES.
YOU CAN PICK ANY RACE I'M GOING
TO MENTION HERE.
THAT'S FINE.
WE HAVE MARCO RUBIO IN FLORIDA.
TAKE HIM OFF THE TABLE.
I'M NOT WORRIED ABOUT JOHN
KENNEDY, RAND PAUL, TIM SCOTT OR
CHARLES GRASSLEY.
BUT WE HAVE RUBIO NOW UP BY
DOUBLE DIGITS.
I GUESS WE CAN ADD HIM TO THAT
LIST.
BUT WE HAVE HERSCHEL IN GEORGIA
AGAINST RAPHAEL WARNOCK.
WE HAVE TED BUDD IN
NORTH CAROLINA AND GENERAL
BOLDUC IN NEW HAMPSHIRE.
RON JOHNSON IS DOING BETTER IN
WISCONSIN.
WE HAVE J.D. VANCE IN OHIO.
WE HAVE ERIC SCHMIDT IN
MISSOURI.
WE HAVE IN ARIZONA BLAKE
MASTERS.
WE HAVE ADAM LAXALT.
THEN THE OTHER RACES THAT WE'RE
PAYING ATTENTION TO LIKE TIFFANY
SMILEY IN WASHINGTON, JOE O'DEA
IN THE STATE OF COLORADO.
WHICH ONES IF YOU HAD TO PICK
DAY 11 DAYS OUTSIDE THE
ELECTION, WHICH STATES WOULD YOU
PREDICT GO RED ON ELECTION DAY?
>> I THINK YOU END UP WITH OZ,
WALKER AND I BELIEVE THAT
MASTERS GETS OVER THE HUMP.
I THINK SMILEY IS IN A DOGFIGHT
AND POSSIBLE.
I WOULD GIVE AN EDGE NOW TO
BOLDUC WINNING.
I DON'T THINK O'DEA GETS CLOSE
ENOUGH.
>> Sean: J.D. VANCE, YOU DON'T
WORRY ABOUT HIM OR RON JOHNSON
IN WISCONSIN.
>> RIGHT.
>> Sean: MATT, YOUR TAKE.
>> THE INCUMBENTS, THEY'RE ALL
SAFE.
LET'S TALK ABOUT SOME OF THESE
OTHER RACES.
HERSCHEL WALKER GETS IN A
RUN-OFF OR WINS STRAIGHT UP.
ARIZONA MASTERS, FOUR POINTS
DOWN TWO WEEKS AGO FOR THE FOX
AFFILIATE IN PHOENIX.
NOW IT'S TWO POINTS AND LAKE IS
RISING SO QUICKLY AND SO
STRONGLY AS A REPUBLICAN
GUBERNATORIAL CANDIDATE, I THINK
THAT COULD BE A SWEEP AND
MASTERS COULD WIN.
LAXALT WILL WIN.
PENNSYLVANIA, THE BOTTOM IS
FALLING OUT OF FETTERMAN'S
CAMPAIGN AFTER THAT DEBATE.
YOU SAW A HUGE MOVE WHEN WE HALL
OUR POLL IN PENNSYLVANIA FOR THE
FOX AFFILIATE IN PENNSYLVANIA.
HERE'S THE ISSUE.
SO MANY PEOPLE HAVE ALREADY
EARLY VOTED AND DIDN'T SEE THE
DEBATE.
OZ WON THE DEBATE 54% TO 20%
AMONG THOSE THAT SAW IT.
I DON'T KNOW.
IT'S A PHOTO FINISH IN
PENNSYLVANIA PARTIALLY BECAUSE
SO MANY PEOPLE HAD VOTED BEFORE
THEY SAW THIS DEBATE.
I THINK THE SAME-DAY VOTE AND
THE REST OF THE VOTE WILL BE
EXTREMELY WEIGHTED IN THE
DIRECTION OF OZ AFTER THAT
PERFORMANCE BY FETTERMAN.
>> Sean: LET ME ASK YOU BOTH
THIS.
WE SEE THAT JOE BIDEN IS HIDING
OUT IN DELAWARE WHILE JILL BIDEN
AND BARACK OBAMA ARE BEING
BROUGHT IN AS SURROGATES IN A
LOT OF THE STATES WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT.
DO YOU SEE ANY IMPACT THAT THEY
COULD HAVE ON THESE RACES.
>> NO.
>> Sean: NONE?
SIMPLY ANSWER.
ROBERT, ANY IMPACT?
>> CONSIDERING THAT JOE WOULD BE
A NEGATIVE ONE, I'LL SAY ZERO.
>> Sean: SO BARACK OBAMA WILL BE
OF NO HELP TO DEMOCRATIC
CANDIDATES?
>> HE COULD IN PLACES LIKE
ATLANTA AND FULTON COUNTY.
HE MIGHT INCREASE THE INTEREST
IN THE TURNOUT A LITTLE BIT.
THE AFRICAN AMERICAN TURNOUT IN
GEORGIA HAS TICKED DOWN IN EARLY
VOTING.
STARTED OUT AT 36%, WHICH IS
ROBUST TO IN GEORGIA, THERE HAS
TO BE A TURNOUT OF 33%.
IN TODAY IN EARLY VOTING, IT'S
DOWN TO 30%.
SO BARACK OBAMA HAS GOT A LOT OF
WORK TO DO TO PULL THESE
CANDIDATES THROUGH.
>> IT'S NOT GOING TO BE STACEY.
IF HE'S GOING TO HELP WARNOCK,
HE HAS A LOT TO DO IN A SHORT
PERIOD OF TIME.
I DON'T SEE IT WORKING.
>> Sean: ROBERT?
>> NOT TO MENTION SO MANY OF
THESE AFRICAN AMERICAN VOTERS
WILL VOTE NORWALKER AND KEMP.
SO YOU HAVE TO BE CAREFUL WHO
YOU TURN OUT.
WHEN THEY HAVEN'T BROKEN IN TO
80 YET.
70% OF THE PEOPLE ARE VOTING FOR
HIM, AND TURNING HIM OUT MIGHT
NOT BE THE PANACEA THEY THINK IT
IS.
>> Sean: I DON'T THINK ANYBODY
CAN HELP STACEY ABRAMS AT THIS
POINT.
SHE'S RUN THE WORST CAMPAIGN OF
ANY